top yep and here he is with the white
pieces against Vincent kymer 19 year old
against a 17 year old who would you hold
as a favorite in this game Simon
well Hans has the advantage of the white
pieces so we're gonna see you know if
that he can use that Advantage so I
would say uh I'll go I'll go for hands
in this one yeah
yeah but then again Vincent teased
another Prodigy of course he's a bit
younger than Hanson he's shown Potential
from a very young age he won this huge
tournament in grenka I think he was 12
years old ahead of several Grandmasters
stormed to Victory there and he's a bit
older now more experienced and his
levels uh steadily and he's increasing
he's got a decent coach as well I mean
if you want to get one coach in the
world that's a good question if you
could pick one guy to be your coach
obviously David is like my top one with
your Banker you know so
um but yeah I mean Peter leco it is
Vincent's coach and has been for a while
so you know with his fast knowledge
that's got to help a lot so who would
you you know who would you go for and
you as well Kaya as your coach yeah one
person anyone in the world I think it
would have to be you Simon because uh
then we can talk about the names of the
pieces there would be do you actually
want to improve
and now you resign
perfect
yeah Peter lecko people know him
nowadays as commentator great chess
player but he was also a prodigy like
these two yeah he was very good very
young so I think it helps to have
someone that you can who's been on a
similar journey to yourself no matter
what the level is if someone's
experienced similar things then that
must be a bonus and uh meanwhile this
started as an English opening it's kind
of a mix between an English opening and
a reti now it's something we call flank
opening because white doesn't occupy the
center with pawns instead it's Black
Vincent kaima here who has a space
advantage in the middle
but white is very quick to develop white
king will Castle now or at least in the
next couple of moves then Hans needs to
fight in the center of the board hands
needs to push and pawns he needs to chip
away at Black's stronghold in the middle
if you don't fight for space or if you
can't then black just has a beautiful
position it's almost as if black is
playing with the white pieces normally
white is the one taking space
so it's very important at an early stage
it's already a critical moment to and uh
okay Hans pushes this Pawn looks a bit
slow to me
I guess his idea to develop his dark
Squad Bishop yeah yeah I agree you know
he's going to develop dark Square bishop
and once he's castled the king just to
do anything he can to get a pawn break
there on the left
and if he can achieve that then okay
then he will stand quite well there will
be a lot of dynamic chances so I think
it's like a spring at the minute he's
going to spring back and then jump
forward
positionally very risky though this way
of playing with white when you've got
the white pieces you kind of don't want
to lose space normally straight away
this is one of the opening openings
where you give black a space advantage
and that means your play is harder cramp
positions harder to play and a
positional problem is that that Bishop
could be terrible stuck behind black
spawn Black's Pawn in the middle of the
board is a real problem for white and
white hasn't done this Pawn break if
white white has to do something about
this Pawn otherwise it's just going to
be worse so I'm I I'm actually really
liking Black's position and would really
want to be black and you know
indestruction nearly always
um yeah I don't want to say nightmare
but it's been a bad opening by white I
feel yeah
it's yeah it's as you've mentioned Simon
it's super risky but also just the move
order he's chosen somehow he hasn't got
the pawn breaks there's two points you
can push with white uh maybe we can show
what Hans is planning now at least he
has a clear plan on his next move
um but that has been stopped so there's
only two ideas here for white
essentially you have to push this Pawn
but the square is covered three times by
Black's pieces that's not easy or you
push this Pawn to try and triple in the
center the reason you have to push pawns
here exchange things off is because
you're quite cramped black has extra
splits extra space this black pawn is in
the white Camp uh White has to fight
against this Duo but if you push your
eport now after Black's last developing
move then suddenly there's a problem uh
black will simply capture trade off and
say thank you very much I've won a pawn
hitting your queen now and hitting your
Rook as well so uh Hans has to prepare
this Pawn push he's doing that in a
logical way but a bit of a slow way
again bringing his Rook across
and uh still no threat I'm just
wondering whether black takes the time
out now to kind of uh just move the
queen or do you push a pawn and just
it's quite nice to kind of have an
escape Square for your Bishop if you
need
uh in the future I'm trying to look for
other ideas here quite typical would be
to relocate this Knight over to this
side of the board at some point uh put
pressure on White's weaknesses over
there
it just looks like a kind of dream
position normally you see this type of
thing with colors reversed yeah but
black here I think has the advantage
yeah totally agree I like your your pawn
move that you made with Harry just give
the bishop a light a little bit of a
refuge and I'm very sorry yeah I just
I'm really surprised by what Hans has
done I mean
uh I've played this kind of position
maybe on like reverse colors and you
just don't do this you mean you're
you're planning for Pawn break you're
not planning to sit there with your
pieces just blocked and then by your
opponent's pawns sorry van I was just
thinking that as you say if you can move
both the e-pawns which are the ones
which start in front of the king if you
can just take them off the board then
white is is doing absolutely fine in
those positions but with those pawns on
the board it makes a massive difference
right because white can't get counter
play uh well in many areas of the board
so it's very hard for for white to ever
play this King's Pawn push this one in
the middle of the board how's it he
needs to play this move but as you say
Ivanka you can't really play it right so
yeah I totally agree with you that's why
I like this last move uh just on that
point I mean the bishop looks like it's
on a block square but it's kind of
eyeing up indirectly any potential Pawn
push white wants to make I mean there's
two problems you just can never make
this Pawn push these two Bishops will
just suddenly open up
and if you can't make these bomb pushes
what are you doing I mean the only thing
I can see for white is to maybe move
this Knight out the way uh try to bring
your knight into the center try to trade
off a set of minor pieces
if you can trade off one set of minor
pieces at least you're the remaining uh
the rest of your army won't feel as
cramped as they do right now but I'm not
sure you this uh this will even work for
example
um Black Knight might just Retreat and
if you now try to jump into the center
black will happily step back and the
Knights are still kind of in this uh in
the way of each other he does go for
this hands I think it was just the only
um I think the only sensible logical
idea here for white
but uh okay if you can get this night
jump if you can try a set of pieces off
he's still like he's still alive but uh
black is the one with the advantage for
sure right now all right it's just the
type of opening you choose if you're in
a must-win situation uh just taking huge
amounts of risk kind of breaking the
rules uh kind of going against
conventional wisdom also there are ideas
now that this Pawn is a bit weak there
are ideas of black just moving attacking
this Pawn
a couple of times yeah it just looks
okay he does yeah he does play this and
White's Queen steps back Hans has
predicted this defending this way
I mean Vincent's he's a very classical
player just like his coach Peter leko
and he's very uh kind of I've analyzed
with him I played him in the groundswiss
late last year he's very condemning if
his opponents do something that they
shouldn't or that he thinks they
shouldn't so he will be determined for
Vincent to try and punish this opening
Choice by Neiman is that a kind of
personality strength and so weakness at
the same time if your opponent has like
if someone has such definite opinions as
to whether things are mistake or
something good yeah I mean you can
kind of play off that character trait
against them as you mentioned Ivanka
like sometimes if I know I'm playing
very correct players I'll try and
provoke them I'll try and say okay I'm
going to be a bit a bit kind of quirky
with this move they'll come at me and at
least then we'll get a proper fight but
uh whatever happens when we play yeah
sorry Simon never provoke me I want to
be provoked by you David please provoke
me next time one day maybe so in the
meantime it's just about whether Hansen
even has time to bring his Knight back
and trade off
one set of pieces maybe black can I like
this night movie you showed
um at some point yeah maybe here I mean
maybe you can allow that Bishop to be
traded I mean is it such a bad thing
because positionally I mean if you look
at just look at the pieces this is also
a very typical move but just looking at
pieces and positions like this you just
got to work out which pieces are you
happy to exchange which you're not happy
to exchange and if white is left with
his Bishop on the dark squares then he's
always going to be in some trouble
because forever that Bishop is in a cage
so you just got to think well I can
actually trade off most of the other
pieces as long as that one stays there
um and well again I we see white just
just trying to find some way to break
and defend at the same time here but
it's just so hard to play cramped
positions that that's the main issue
with white structure here and black at
some point can build up to making a push
in the center is logical but you can you
can get his pieces to the best squares
first yeah so I like this idea Simon
just dropped back and you're ready to
push this Pawn at the right moment if
necessary to control over uh the E4
Square as you mentioned I mean as long
as you never let this guy out the cage
it should be okay
so yeah let's go back to the players
right now still very tense uh we've been
a bit harsh maybe on Newman's opening
choice but it has led to quite a unique
scenario with all the pieces still on
the board at move 15. and a lot of
tension ahead some difficult decisions I
guess with uh this we've said it in the
past with great space comes great
responsibility so Vincent he's kind of
pushed all the black pieces pawns
forward you'd still need to kind of
justify that by covering all the squares
behind
um I wouldn't be surprised either one of
the black Rooks just centralizes now
there's plenty of choice
and uh yeah style wise maybe this will
suit Newman he lately has kind of just
played this provocative style he likes
to kind of create this tension and
um he's got great nerves hands uh there
we go the Knight does retreat as we
suggested
and there is a threat on white tonight
now the black queen has opened up threat
I think that Knight just has to step
back into the center
whereas to go only way to justify your
previous play
but uh is that if you if you've been to
the center I mean that night I get
trapped can I get trapped
there's going to be some questions being
asked and uh maybe the other night can
jump into the center
um one of the two white Knights just has
to start mobilizing right
yeah well it has to do something right
white just can't keep doing nothing I
mean something has to give you have to
come forward
has anyone ever won a game by not
actually doing a pawn break
this is very famous game
um old Anderson against basman
um from Hastings in 70s and um it's
amazing because uh basman doesn't really
do anything on his first three ranks he
just he just sits there and he waits and
he's playing like the master of
positional chess he waits he waits his
weights and then he wins so that's the
only game I can think of it was at the
Hastings competition but
um I don't know if you know the game I
know it's yeah I've seen it you've seen
it just came back and forth yeah really
yeah he literally he just when he moves
he just yeah there's nothing here like
it like maybe a modern day computer
would nowadays you know literally modern
day computers and blocked positions they
often move their their King battles or
forwards and so basman was the the
originator of the wait and see method
creative yeah he was a brilliantly
creative player and Olf Anderson and I
hope everyone knows his name was an
amazing player as well see yeah yeah and
uh I've played games where I still have
Pawns for example on E2 D2 F2 until move
40 Beyond but at some point you need to
start pushing them that's uh that's the
problem often if you leave pawns doing
nothing then you don't control important
squares and okay meanwhile
Vincent is trying to force a decision
from Neiman what's he gonna do with his
Knight on the G5 Square this Pawn push
attacks at night also creates some
Escape squares for the black king later
multi-purpose move
but at least white has the opportunity
at some point
maybe to step pulling forward in the
center now just Retreat that night
and there we go it comes back and now
this Pawn push we've been talking about
White's epon maybe he's ready to play it
at some point
it still feels very loose if you don't
time it correctly uh as Neiman here
but uh both players playing very fast as
well we've got to praise this both very
confident
because there's so many options on every
turn I would be here sitting just
thinking okay I've got four tempting
moves for black how do I choose what do
I choose but uh I think Vincent I I
would be delighted through this piece
I'd be like to see the king I'm just
going to push support and worry about it
later
I'm just too impatient I'll be like that
night in the middle it's annoying me
I'll Attack it I'll check mate thank you
very much cheers
itchy fingers Williams this is my
nickname so it's yeah we're so different
Simon I would just never I would move
that Bishop away I would be like I mean
and then and then I would put your plan
into operation the only the only reason
I wouldn't move that Bishop I just
wonder if it gives white more chances to
push on the queen side probably not
though probably moving the bishop ways
you don't want to exchange pieces you're
right
um I I'm sort of you know that is true
but there are some choices we're already
discussing them right and that that is
that's the problem with having okay
there you go the best moves played Simon
loses again but the problem with having
a good position is that it's actually
trickier right yeah or maybe oh yeah
yeah
there you go a bit of f5ing was on there
but it's hard when you've got a good
position because you've got more choice
and having more Choice causes more
problems right special life as well
maybe so yeah exactly it can cause
indecisiveness especially with 10
minutes on the clock you could burn five
or six of those minutes easily just on
deciding between two very good moves
uh yeah you just have to trust your
instinct there and I guess instant
trusted is Instinct I know his coach
Peter lecko and I think Vincent they
love the two Bishops so
this is just a kind of stylistic thing
I'm pretty sure your move was good too
Simon but uh I I mean there is even if
you've got a beautiful position at some
point you have to do something you know
well unless you're basmine but you can't
you can't sit around forever you have to
change the essence of the position if
you might have the most beautiful
position in the world that you need to
do something with it to to win the game
and you know you need to destroy that
beautiful position to actually do
something concrete and it's it's you
know it's hard to do that when things
look so nice
but I gave me this bishop Despicable Me
doesn't look bad for sure I mean I think
the more I look at it more I'm like yes
it can be really good move I kind of
prefer that one keep the pieces on take
your time it's move 18 now when do you
think we'll see the first capture First
Pawn disappearing or first piece
disappearing it's still all 32 pieces on
the board
26 26. okay okay these eight more moves
before the first capture Ivanka
I'm gonna be a little less
I think I'm gonna say actually I'm going
to be even more ambitious maybe four
moves okay Kaya
when is the first exchange gonna happen
24. okay I'll say 20.
just in case I think you might put your
phone in the center now all right I was
trying to Bluff you guys into going high
and then I'll go look what did I say did
I say eight moves 26. okay ah no you
might be right he doesn't go for any
action yet any money he's just
maneuvering but that night just came
from this Square two moves ago yes wow
this is it's weird as if it's as if he's
really trying to force Kmart to come
forward he's heard about he's heard
about the BET and he wants to yeah
we could easily be a bit more
maneuvering I mean you know black could
try to move his Rook into the middle try
to improve his Knight maybe even push
the H but I don't know push a pawn
somewhere but what's white doing you
know he's lost time with his pieces I
think if my opponent played a move like
that for my first instinct would
actually be not to go totally aggressive
as I had before but to play a move like
this because I know that my opponent's
not doing anything if my opponent's not
doing anything why why I should just
need to improve you know improve my
position little by little
so I like this movie I like this move I
mean I was totally shocked by it I met
because I was just expecting the very
direct approach of pushing pawns but
this one is nice because it has the plan
of actually trading light squared
Bishops on H3 uh well well well
well what move are we on we could see it
because she's a porn trade it could be
to exchange or not to exchange if
there's a capture now I don't know if I
win the betas move 19 not 20. it's
Black's 19th you're pretty close aren't
you yeah
I mean would you take care though I mean
no it's a good question right so I think
the first I mean we've mentioned a
couple of critical moments but the first
big big critical moment is now why it's
just pushed forward and on passant uh it
was mentioned actually in that song the
pawns lament uh on passant
do you capture this Pawn as if it just
moved one square or do you let it bypass
you if you just block things up if you
just move your knight it still looks
great right I mean you're attacking this
Pawn which is a Eternal weakness a White
Queen has to come and defend it at some
point you can just build up the black
rook and come across maybe later you
play for this Pawn push yourself
that being said it is blocked and if
white can maybe move his Knight to the
edge of the board and start pushing the
F Pawn forward it looks like a king's
Indian defense just with colors reversed
and we all know that how tricky those
can be for both sides to play
the option is however to capture on
passant white will take back
and what next
I mean this is a pin but can you use it
I don't really see your weight oh the
first capture has happened guys I think
it'll win a day yeah I got lucky move
20. yeah now the bar says that hands is
better wow unbelievable so quickly did
that turn as soon as he broke out uh the
bar bars changed in his favor yeah okay
and uh I guess there's some potential uh
some potential activity on this diagonal
if you can open up the center then white
has some check mating ideas this Pawn is
however quite strong at the moment
there are also ideas of white stepping
forward with his own Pawn yeah I don't
like this decision by black I think you
have to be patient and just allow things
to block up
and re-maneuver I mean structurally now
white is better you say more Pawns in
the center uh generally means you're
better and look at you know we said that
dark Square Bishop we said if that
bishop ever comes alive white should be
okay it was looking at a brick wall in
the center but now it's looking like one
of White's most powerful pieces so I I
think this is certainly changing
enhanced favor yeah I did someone did
tell me the other day that Hans just got
offered a a million dollars to appear
naked
um
would you appear naked for a million
dollars people and I'd do anything
if they're naked for free
so tomorrow here make sure you tune in
because actually I should have said at
least okay at least 10 quid
crowdfunding people David to appear
naked on the chairs
yeah you can play here naked if you want
I mean it might be a bit distracting
yeah I'm sorry I promise I won't do that
I won't I don't want to give anyone
nightmares
but yeah that was a serious uh proposal
from some sort of a sponsor it was yes I
think some sponsor had offered I don't
know the truth that you never know of
all these things that are going on it
could be rubbish but it seemed like it
was a serious sponsor a million dollars
if you played chess naked
um I mean that's like maybe the biggest
paid chess match ever internet you know
in the history so it's it's especially
if it's just one game one if it's one
game naked then yeah that's incredible
yeah so yeah and we can pass it off as
art right yeah maybe maybe it's like
they're making it 50-hour game or
something I don't know
you want to play naked with hands
or do you have to be naked as well or
just uh
um
right now white is breaking forward and
Hans played that move instantly without
thinking looking good for white the
momentum's on his side it's a very
natural move as well
just about those pawns they were
completely stuck now after a recapture
which he'll also play um we go it's
night had to jump in and it's just a bit
of a calculation right now this is a
fork blacks
night now it's deep in enemy territory
attack also attacking White's dark
squared Bishop this is yeah I mean um
hands is really taking control and I
love the way he he you know you've got
to take your opportunity um if your
position's a bit tough and he's taken it
so attacking the queen but what's going
on here I can't calculate this I mean
this is incredibly fast calculation I
must say by hands because Black's Queen
doesn't necessarily even need to move
you could make an argument for capturing
uh porn in the center right now with
blacks Bishop for example you can make
an argument for taking whites dark
Square Bishop with the Black Knight
there's a lot to calculate he's just I
mean his instincts are great hunts we've
seen that in his streaming and
everything and
yeah maybe he's just trying to unsettle
Vincent with the speed of his moves
suddenly a big clock Advantage as well
yeah I think we have to jump in and show
what is happening right now yeah
confident play yeah confident play and
uh he's narrowed the path now for
Vincent as well black has options but uh
they're all very sharp all very concrete
the queen is attacked first of all by
the White Knight if the queen moves to a
bad square if the queen loses connection
with her Knight then this Knight Falls
for example if you move white will
simply take that Knight off the board
win a piece so either you Retreat and
you go back but then the queen looks
really badly placed here
um there are always going to be ideas of
the bishop coming to attack her even
further or you have to start calculating
and that's why both players have their
heads in their hands right now for
example you could take this Pawn with a
check hitting the king uh the White
Queen I guess is going to recapture you
take back white tonight takes the queen
and
everything's hanging I mean I have no
idea what's happening this Rook is
hanging this Knight is hanging this this
Knight is hanging
this Rook is hanging I mean I could draw
all the arrows here because everything's
Under Fire and
how do you even start calculating this
position
um I mean you just need three or four
minutes here just to get to grips with
things
um here I guess the alternative would be
okay he does go for this uh Vincent I
think it was just process of elimination
black had nothing else I was going to
say maybe you could take this bishop but
uh that wasn't quite working so he does
take a check the Queens are going to
disappear and we're going to see this
weird position with all the minor pieces
very loose right now
I mean do you take this Knight do you
take this Rook I guess you take one of
them
struggling here to calculate myself I
must admit
it does look like white is going to
emerge quite decently why it's going to
emerge with two nice Bishops assuming
black doesn't win material white will
have these this bishop on a great
diagonal this bishop on a great diagonal
and so the sticks are high for Vincent
he needs to somehow eliminate those
pieces
so complicated I mean uh it's good you
know I can see why Vincent's using his
time here I have to say I did just see a
quite funny comment
um someone's suggesting that you know
maybe only hands.com could um be
something that hands could create
before I was quite a funny website we
have creatives for we have very creative
views every day but yeah I mean still in
the balances right I mean you can see
even the valuation bar but you know that
isn't a balance but
um it does seem to me that this is
another very powerful move that track
Vincent has to be more more careful at
the moment in this tactical position so
yeah I mean temporarily we should also
mention the black is a piece down but
black had a choice of which piece to
capture there a moment ago I think again
Vincent's just surviving by process of
elimination uh the more I looked at it
the more I thought actually those other
captures weren't quite working so uh
yeah therefore you look for a check
now white has two legal moves either you
Shuffle to the corner with the white
king or you capture this Knight if you
capture this Knight it's going to be a
bunch more trades
um okay what's the material balance
white gives a check
I'm trying to count here white has two
pieces for blacks Rook
so white is maybe marginally better if
everything else was equal
but it's still so irrational this
position
uh okay Hans instantly moves this Rook I
think that was also pretty much a forced
move the Rook was attacked by Black's
Bishop The Rook needed to defend the
white dark Squad Bishop
so tricky to comprehend here white
tonight is almost trapped but it can
Retreat to two squares right now
the Privacy evaluation bar is in the
middle because
it just looks like someone should be
better I'm not sure who I mean that was
so complicated maybe they both just
played perfectly there I mean every move
is a forcing move pretty much everybody
it's uh really sharp and I think it's
you know if we just count the material
if white can maybe just consolidate a
little bit in the two minor pieces are
nearly always better than the Rook
important and white has the Knight and
the bishop for blacks rook and pawn so
generally those pieces are better than
your opponent's work unless you get into
the ending if you get into the ending
this is like the one General case where
the Rook is stronger so I think you know
there's more danger for black uh sorry
at the moment yeah yeah the stakes are
higher at least and yeah yeah I I mean
I'm inclined to agree I would probably
choose white here
um and I think that's one one area where
maybe beginners or Club players they
they do sometimes struggle to evaluate I
know I struggled until I was uh quite a
lot older do you choose the rook in the
pawn or sometimes even rook and two
pawns or do you choose two minor pieces
of Bishop at night because a rook and
pawn bishop of Knight materially the
same both worth six points but
you nearly always choose two pieces
right anyways I mean there's some lots
of receptions to all rules in chess and
um I remember Mikhail Tower was very
famous for sacrificing and they say
sacrifice had been taken the Rook
against the two minor pieces but only in
particular situations where he had a
raging uh initiative so you know it has
to go by Case by case you can't
generalize that much in chess really how
about this case then uh I definitely
take white now it seems like white okay
he has got the two knights of rock and
pawn but they seem to be coordinating
pretty well here
um you know unless
I don't know you know if white can just
consolidate this move is King something
like that then I definitely take white
hair I I had a rule that actually um was
said by Sam shankland and he said just
to help you in these type of positions
look to the Rooks they will determine
whether it's actually good because if
the Rooks can move and they can create
useful posts or they can defend
weaknesses then they're okay but uh if
not then the minor pieces are better how
about blackstrokes yeah I mean I don't
know I mean because you can envisage a
future where the Rooks are actually
dominating
but here you know they have some open
lines to go down I'm not sure about that
last move I thought maybe he could do
something else but okay maybe this is
okay and uh it just seems to be very
very balanced actually maybe if I were
to
pick a side it would be white because I
feel that the nights are just going to
be easier to maneuver and they're going
to be easier just to
um well it's easier for white to attack
points yeah those white Knights look
good I like your idea Simon just uh
bring this King into the game at the
right moment there's a question actually
here about I was just going to say this
last move do you rush uh by kind of
creating a post for your night or do you
just calmly bring the king in here he
has created a nice Outpost for the White
Knight to sit on that's going to be a
dominant Square for the White Knight if
it reaches
D6 I don't know what black does here to
be honest do you need to get the other
Rook into the game for example maybe you
could give a check activate one piece at
least and then try to activate this
piece just before it's too late bring it
to an open file at least now the White
Knight if it jumps in at least you have
a safe Square for your Rook you defend
everything
and uh at least you control some squares
on this file
I mean this Knight just looks beautiful
though
to be honest
yeah I mean also Black's pawns on the
queen side you've kind of caught them in
a position where they can't move and and
they you know you can easily attack them
uh later on they could just drop off at
some point if you get this structure you
pointed out David I mean that that looks
like a very powerful plan that Hans has
found there I think this is you know the
only idea is to try to dislodge those
Knights and try to you know make sure
they don't consolidate on good squares
and G5 seems Seems like the right right
way to go at least four sat nights go
backwards yeah and if the Knight
Retreats then at least it's not in a
good circuit anymore it's just about
this one how do we stop this one uh from
becoming a good piece
yes not so easy maybe you just don't
maybe you just have to accept it
um I like the idea of giving a check and
then mobilizing one rook and then using
the other Rook just to anchor the two
black pawns yep and this is one idea
maybe you could make an argument first
starting to push this Pawn forward now
just kind of a more aggressive ambitious
approach but either way Vincent is low
on the clock now five minutes down and
he's facing the prospect of the White
Knight jumping into this dream Outpost
one game is finished two players are
finished for the day and it's another
great game by Magnus crossing a win
three points against the Liam who's been
a top player in the tour this season so
Magnus winning three games today one
draw it's been a fantastic first day for
the world number one
we are calling him right now hoping for
a comment from World number one
yeah I mean I mean he's really started
on fire normally we're not used to
seeing him kind of this shop so soon in
tournaments normally he steps up the
gears as the days go on but uh
impressive stuff scary for the rest of
the field Maybe
have you been impressed by his play
today as well of course results are
great yeah I've been looking over and
Magnus doing Magnus things just
provoking his opponents playing some
creative openings and uh just great
technique as soon as he gets the
advantage yeah this is uh the live table
in the tournament Magnus call is now on
10 out of 12 possible points
he is the only one who's finished the
together with Liam Lee who's stuck on
two points not a good first day for Liam
Lee pregnant if he wins his game he's
gonna be in solid with 12 points winning
all three games so far today pragnananda
and Magnus currently on top of the table
with 10 points massive first day and
tomorrow Magnus will play Hans name on
The game everyone is looking forward to
in round six tomorrow
second round of the day tomorrow
these two will face off in an intense
battle is what we're supposed to suspect
now in this one Hans has also had a good
first day he did lose in the last round
but
a win here and he would be all the way
towards the top of the table what's the
most likely result right now
I don't want to disagree with the
computer too often but here I've got to
say a white win is uh probably more
likely than a draw just from what I can
see unless I'm I mean I'm clearly
misevaluating because the computer
thinks it's roughly balanced but I would
choose white every time
yeah and also the time situation yeah I
mean the computer can't really take that
into account and the time situation now
is uh Vincent going under one minute and
hands continuing to play his normal fast
speed I mean okay so he's going for the
most aggressive move and I you know I
think he's got to try to create this
counter play now but uh it's definitely
I mean does the Knight come back even
now I mean the retreating night moves
are hard moves to play going forwards is
the very natural move but going
backwards must be the other candidate
move the one that you consider because
you can make more exchanges that way
yeah
um but maybe going forwards is still
normal it's still very attempting to
LEAP uh into the black Camp here but
yeah I think this was a winning threat
actually White's night to retreat uh so
uh Vincent he had to either move the
black bishop or defend it and he chooses
to defend it the White Knight does
indeed jump forward the White Knight
stepping back to attack the black Rook
yep
also on the radar but at least he gets
this move Vincent uh very nice idea so
you mentioned Simon those black queen
side pawns they couldn't move now at
least uh you can push it or the computer
disagrees but um you can push it just
because that white knight was being
destabilized and well some tricky night
Forks incoming winning threat again on
the board Hans if he gets time okay he
looks very happy with himself
yeah oh yeah God I like that one hands
flexing his hands yeah but uh has he got
winning moved out here he is he's played
it just just winning material and the
game probably instantly and this we have
to explain why this is winning uh let's
keep an eye on the players because we
could see Vincent even resign because
he's lost simply uh after portex porn
what else was uh convincing to do the
white knight leaps forward it's a double
attack on this Rook White's Bishop is
hitting it White's Knight is healing it
so if you move it I mean firstly what
Square do you choose if you choose this
one this is a fork this is the secondary
threat uh a double attack and you win a
piece
white will emerge with an extra Knight
you can't save both your Rooks in the
current position uh so a threat to
capture here but also a threat to jump
forward
game over wow just nice geometry there
really nice geometry by Hans Neiman he
kind of danced around with his Knights
he left this night's uh kind of hanging
uh kind of he retreated it for a second
but then leaps forward at the right
moment and yeah not much to do white
tonight is going to give a check just to
piece up pretty much I mean okay A
little bit of work to do but at this
level shouldn't be that much and uh I
mean it was uh in the recent sort of
press stuff that's come come out it was
a God who said that he's worked with
hands they got a very respected coach
and he was um praising hands on his
one-on-one tuition just how strong hands
was at spotting tactics as he's showing
here and also just his work effort as
well and uh well we can see that apron's
gonna win the game and he's just mopping
everything up here so yeah let's move
yeah he gobbled up one Pawn he covered
up a second and uh the current material
count is a whole night up for white
not much to do here for Vincent
unfortunately this white a pawn is also
past pawn it will start motoring up the
board
in a moment the White Knight gets out
the way first and then this is going to
start to run
yeah
I think for it and uh Vincent is he
gonna give up yeah it looks uh like it
yeah
uh looks like it yep there it is it's
another win for Hans Neymar no big one
against uh his fellow teenager Vincent
kymer to end a great day